on the streets of limbae a city in
cameroon's south west province it's not
just fans who are taking pictures
it's a matter of days until africa's
most prominent soccer championship the
africa cup of nations and security is
tight
six cities are hosting afcon matches but
limbae and nearby boya are in the
spotlight because separatist fighters
have warned the games should not be
played there my fear and the fear of
many limb denizens is that the recent
phenomenon of
bomb blasts
which has been happening in other parts
of our code division like in bowie
can be a common phenomenon during this
afghan
period
conflict broke out in cameroon in 2016
between english-speaking separatists and
the french-speaking government
the armed groups accused the government
of discriminating against them and want
to form a breakaway state called
ambassonia
the fightings killed at least 3 000
people and forced about a million from
their homes
some rights groups say any violence
could threaten teams and spectators and
the competition should be called off
cameroon hosted the african nations
championships in january and february
2021
the governing body of african football
and cameroon's government are promising
a safe tournament
i can't reveal the measures that are
being put in place but you should know
that just as the african nations
championship took place under very good
conditions afcon will also take place
under very good conditions there's
nothing to worry about
cameroon won the right to host the
finals when its team beat egypt in 2017
ending a 15-year drought
it's already been pushed back twice once
because of concerns about cameroon's
preparations and then by the pandemic
some hope it will provide a much needed
financial boost
we do believe
it will boom our business because so
many customers who come from different
areas different towns different
countries
we meet so many
other people that will meet new friends
make new friends
others though say they won't be able to
focus on the games while some and
cameroon live in fear for their lives
alex o'brien al jazeera